speaking of human sucking i uh i saw
this recent thing okay uh that uh
what a segway
i mean because i i looked at this and i
thought oh my god humans suck but there
was an article that came out about not
too long ago i'll just write yahoo who's
the article first uh there's a lot of
different articles that came out uh all
over the place but uh i'll just read the
i'll just read the title of this article
because it explains everything go for it
lonely ape has just launched a dating
app for nft collectors a dating app a
dating app somebody has developed a
dating app specifically for nft bros
to date nft host
i don't i i think the problem with this
is
is that everything there is well
but let's now let's
i'm going to take a second okay what do
you reckon the demographic of people who
have nfts are okay okay
okay okay jojo's dating app it's going
to work
let's look at this positively okay
so what you're saying is we're going to
be removing people with nft profiles
just from our dating pool i i think i
think that's a positive right surely
surely
but that means that we're just like
forcing these kinds of people to
reproduce
which is like force
people who like the nft should not be
allowed to reproduce no i'm not saying
that but you know
you're implying no
well that's okay they they go on the
metaverse it's fine just like but just
like reading through this article just
made me have like several aneurysms uh
there is no need to enter uh or display
personal information instead one can
link their crypto wallet to access the
app
once logged in the user can display
their net worth and nft pro portfolio
what you can also filter your matches by
their cryptocurrency value and the nft
collection
if i had a dollar for every time i saw
an article about something to do with
nfts that i despised i wouldn't need to
buy anything everywhere i was like why
didn't they probably own an nfc
i'd be rich enough to own an energy i
would be very wealthy
i've not seen a single good thing with
an article it's never like nft owners
pledge to uh stop global warming to save
the world and it's like no it's like nft
owners pledge to have a yacht club where
they all wank each other off or
something that's all whatever it is it's
like the uh the nft restaurant thing
it's like it's are you just making uh
are you just trying to make some kind of
tangible effect that you own an nft it's
like
there's some reason there's some reason
wait so so explain what this restaurant
you need to own an ft to go into the
restaurant yeah
that's it that's it that's it that's it
it's like you just like you just go up
to the bounce and you'll be like
i mean
it's getting to the point where it's
just like classism with extra steps now
actually it's not even any extra steps
it's just
well we've hated on fts like so many
times i i just yeah it sucks it sucks
it's yeah i just i just saw that article
and i'm like i i legitimately thought it
was an onion article at first because it
sounds like one day i realized oh the
sad reality that's a real thing even if
they you know they could turn around and
when people back on to nfts which i
don't think they can
i i just can't see them
winning the public faith back in it
again now yeah since everyone has just
seen how much of a mess it's been i
don't you know and whatever you think
about the technology or whatever you
think about what it can be done with it
you have to recognize that the the nft
like this kind of landscape that it had
has become right now yeah such a mess
ripe with scams [ __ ] up [ __ ] money
laundering just every kind of awful
thing you can imagine yeah it has had
such a bad public wrap that it would not
only need to come up with something
revolutionary that is actually good it
would then have to win people back over
by fixing its image which i don't think
it can because the internet doesn't want
to to make it more regulated it doesn't
want to make it more it also just they
like how free it is yeah it also just
seems like that community doesn't really
care about it either no they do they do
do they yeah because they push it on to
everyone and everything well then how
come they're not trying to how come
they're not trying to do anything to
better their image
and instead make these [ __ ] dating
apps and restaurants it's a free-for-all
right now every company and every person
is trying to grab a part of like it's a
gold rush everyone wants that bit of it
yeah so the reason why everyone is
shoving it down everyone's throat is
because they they have investments they
want to make sure they don't lose their
money okay onto the next sucker who
comes in too late yeah and it's like
it's it's also so weird did you see the
clip where it was like i think i think
jimmy fallon like presenting his nft
with a paris hilton like
huh oh of course yeah yeah it's it's uh
is it a meme at least or is it like no
no no it is serious okay so
i believe i believe it's jimmy fallon
but uh the jimmy fallon and paris hilton
uh well paris hilton was on the jimmy
fallon show and they started talking
about nfts and how paris hilton
convinced jimmy fallon to buy a broad
ape nft right it's so
it was so weird because it's like i've
never seen a clip of two people more out
of touch
with like the wider world so they they
like like so jimmy finally brings out
his like he's like bored but it's
brought abroad that's the name yeah yeah
he brings out yeah the monkeys yeah he
brings out his board nft right he goes
he and he goes isn't this beautiful look
at this it's amazing and like you can
hear the audience clapping i've seen
this image i thought it was a meme
really no no it is real image on the
picture yeah and i've i've never heard
such a applause where it was so obvious
that there was a big light saying
applause yes because you could tell the
audience had no idea what the [ __ ] they
were talking about
another massive problem with the whole
nfc landscape right is that it benefits
the people who have big platforms right
if you have a big platform it's free
money for you that's why people are
doing this
the moment something is advertised to
you as you should buy it is the moment
you're it's too late for you to make
anything
you know the moment that consumers are
seeing big names promoting it it's too
late to make money yeah some people
might make money the majority of people
are not going to make money no and the
majority of people are going to lose
money and the people who get money are
people like jimmy fallon people like uh
people are already rich
people who have the platform the power
to push people towards their investment
it's it's a glorified pyramid scheme in
many ways right because it's like how do
you get your money by getting more
people into it yeah right it's it's
that's how it works and that's why
you're seeing like when i tweet anything
or men or or mentioned in anything nft
it doesn't matter what the comment is
these these verified nft accounts like
everything with the with the phrase nft
in it yeah they don't i could be saying
nfts suck and they can gargle on my nuts
and and someone who supports nft will
like that comment just because they've
googled nft and they like everything
because they're trying to get followers
they're trying to get engagement right
so then they can push it more and have
more a bigger sphere of influence what
if they just like gargling or nuts they
might call themselves like they probably
do yeah they do yes please
i hate it i hate it so much because it's
so
obviously a scam like the moment that
you are being
advertised to about buying an investment
is the moment that you've you've already
you can't make money and i think that's
what's so [ __ ] disappointing as well
especially with you know as you said
like big influences right like getting
in on it like [ __ ] you know when i
when i saw that like eminem bought like
an nft of just what looks like a monkey
version of himself i was like
why would you do that
because never before every childhood
you have a big sphere of influence it's
just free money exactly and in their
eyes it's low-risk public image because
you're not asking your
you don't have to it's not like you're
begging your followers for money but
what you're doing is making them pay for
something yeah that makes your thing
more valuable it's heavy incentivizing
right and and you can claim
just that you you're just an investment
it's like you're like buying a stock
it's like no it's not like buying a
house it's not like buying a stock it's
different right there's rules around
buying a shop for reasons right yeah
even though
sometimes the rules are a bit [ __ ]
yeah yeah still
yeah i mean like i'm passionately about
this and i i hate the system so much
well i'm like the only thing i have to
add to this is like do you think this
negative image is purely you know it's
purely based on like the western circle
and just like our perception of the
internet so definitely because because
like i've heard like of that like nfts
have a very very different perception in
like the japanese circles and uh
and you know the japanese especially the
art communities as well because they see
it as
from what i've read at least they've
they they have a much more positive view
of nfts and they see it as like an
opportunity to of course give uh you
know ownership to artists and stuff like
that which is a lot you know given the
cultures i understand why maybe japanese
people would be more
more accepting of this idea because it's
it's like for japanese people and
japanese artists it's a lot bigger
problem than it is i'm i'm awful giving
rights to artists and whatnot but you
know i feel there are other ways that
you can do it if the systems were you
know properly implemented not to mention
that in japan like you know the the
whole copyright laws in japan especially
are just like on the next level of
outdated yeah right right like it's so
like i think if anything the reason why
japanese are gonna yeah of course of
course the japanese are gonna look at
nfts and things like oh this is perfect
like this gets around everything that
we've believed in and done in like a
really cool way that supports artists
like more and more ways to copyright
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah bring it in yeah
that requires the good faith of
all parties involved though yeah like
everyone has to be using it correctly
yeah yeah and the problem is is that
they're not english we're definitely not
you know and there's there's some very
valid reasons to to own nfts or bitcoin
or anything any of these currencies
right like if you live in a if you're
like a russian person right now and all
your money was in the rupal yeah you're
[ __ ] yeah like your money's gone you
just don't you don't own much money
anymore if you had that all in a bitcoin
wallet yeah you'd still be very wealthy
right so that makes more that in those
scenarios it makes a lot of sense the
problem is it's it's kind of replicated
what the fine art world was before
to like the big private investors right
it was basically fine art it was this
glorified
money
money laundering and money
transactioning thing right yeah and now
in the west people figured out huh
you can make a lot of money and money
that you can hide very easily
by doing this nft [ __ ] and so it's kind
of turned into more of a democratized
fine art
yeah [ __ ] for people right like uh like
the whole uh overwatch like tenant did
you watch tenant yeah i watched tenants
you know like the art that was held in
the um
in the airports because it couldn't be
text that's actually a real thing i know
that's a real thing was that a major
part of tenant that was a big uh plot
point and tenant is where they steal the
the they steal the artwork and all the
valuable stuff from the airport
uh holding uh the tax haven in the
airport clearly this movie really made
an impression on god
i just remember things going backwards
like that's like things looking cool
that's like the first time in like media
that i can recall that has like told
people that these things exist yeah yeah
people didn't know these existed before
um you know it just was that a massive
part attendant i feel like i would have
remembered that which scene which which
scene was this in was this in the first
scene i don't remember ever gonna know
the full [ __ ] playlist of ten and i
don't know what [ __ ] happened
i just like they had a big there was a
big plot point about them doing a heist
in the first half of the movie
was there oh my [ __ ] the only thing i
know is that the one's been wrong
he basically did oh my god
when he dies like his life doesn't flash
before his eyes just 10 at the movies
i remember them being in an airport but
i don't remember them
maybe uh they were getting a flight or
something no but they were investigating
the
they were this is a complete [ __ ]
tangible we're going into
they were investigating the phenomena
right that uh that
you know the phenomena where time moves
backwards or something that's that's all
i remember ish i can't remember they're
stealing something they're just holding
because and in the holding places they
normally have art because you can't you
can basically buy and sell in this area
because it doesn't yeah yeah it's not
under any jurisdiction yeah yeah
taxpayer right so you can no i i
remember that being paid i remember the
paintings there i just don't know i just
don't remember that being like a massive
part of the plot point but
it was just like it was like i brought
it up because it was like the first time
it had been addressed or like brought up
in like uh prominent media yeah um well
these things exist yeah well they've
existed for like a very very long time
and it's not just like fine arts but
like and like it's not just paintings
any valuable thing like after stuff in
the british museum
yeah that's normally the place where
they come from you know like
the point was is that it's
i just think with the way that nfts are
structured right now it's just this is
this was obviously going to happen yeah
it was it was it's just been ripe with
scams like half this [ __ ] is awful like
yeah there's some legitimate uses the
technology seems somewhat promising
right now the fact that it uses more
than like most countries the entire like
bitcoin network uses more electricity
than countries yeah is very concerning
yes um
and that there are more you know they're
making new coins they're making new ways
that are much more efficient and stuff
yeah yeah we get it but it's not there
right now
it's not it's not doing that right now
it's not working right now in a way that
works for the world do you think it will
ever work out yeah it definitely will at
some point obviously the idea of having
a way that you can 100 own something
digitally is going to be very convenient
at some point yes
well you said yes yeah yeah
but right now it just doesn't the way
that it's being used is like a joke no i
mean like it's weird it's weird seeing
how fast they just came from like
basically nowhere to everyone talking
about them i mean crypto because it's
been just so like it's just been shoved
down every once in a while
yeah it was literally last year where i
had not heard of the word nft until like
may or april and then i couldn't stop
hearing it i was like i remember being
like i mean i only found out what it was
like
on the [ __ ] podcast podcast yeah yeah
i'm so envious of you joey